the first Cent is clear clearly
according to that they will have six
letters but I want to ask a slightly
different question how many chromosomes
I do have 22 or 24.
so I think they'll definitely be around
in a million years
good question anyway
uh my goal today we are in Institute for
theory of computing so my goal today
first to prove itself
I want everybody in this room biologists
and computer scientists like to
understand all the details
then I want to show how ethereum can
make or break a biological series
and then
if time lows I will show how the selling
will help us hopefully to answer the
question
okay I assume that everybody in this
room has read
the Origin of Species and it shows
because
and it shows because it's currently
number eight the selling book on
Evolution on Amazon and right now I'm
teaching a course reading it so that's
another reason why it is number eight
but I want to talk about number seven
do you know who is number seven
here's number seven
and how many people in this room have
read this book please raise your hand
one two two three
four okay
uh this is also Darwin of course a
century and a half old this book is also
even opinions of this book acknowledge
that it's well written it's intense
Edition 20 years old book more editions
yeah anyway
uh but only four people in this room
have read number seven on best selling
place and
Eugene even New York Times
uh in the review of this book audio that
is an excellent right
I'm talking about writing
okay
anyway
and it brings another book
to talk about you must be grateful Dr
zubag
and you know the doctor was back in
Russia in Soviet Union and Pastor Mark
was almost driven to suicide because
every day there was a paper a letter
from a broker a peasant or a fellow
writer intelligence blaming Pastor knock
for what he's done by for writing
doctors
they would be in prison
and that's why
this letters were starting from a phrase
I haven't read pasta man but I condemned
and of course people in this room
condemned me
right
and I know hope that you can switch you
can switch the microphone like video
stream because I'm going to say
something politically and correct and I
don't want Simonson's not funding to be
effective
it's only preserved for eternity don't
worry okay
and I like it I sinned it's an excellent
set of challenges to Malacca evolution
I'm not religious I'm not supporter of
intelligent design but nice is back here
at least explicitly he made an effort to
separate him he is a professor of
biochemistry it's not a book for Daniels
it's actually sophisticated book to read
you need to know biochemistry a little
bit and nevertheless it is number seven
I said it is an excellent book to give
in the class
to or molecular Evolution to challenge
students and to explain them how to
refute
baking is essentially causes challenges
to Evolution he never talks about the
identity of Creator he is not he made an
effort to distance himself from
intelligent designer however it's so
easy to label them him an intelligent
designer because it's easy this way to
refute his claims can I just inject one
thing I have actually read all of those
things this is the second book that he's
read yes written plus interviews plus a
lot I mean it's one of my advice is I
really get deep into this intelligent
design stuff and he is not as honest as
you are portraying of course yeah that
separation he's claiming is a deception
of course of course it is a very tricky
set to discuss what he's done and unlock
his name is bihi yeah okay but uh but
then how many students biologists let
alone by informaticians in class you
teach would be able to intelligently
refute his arguments how many biology
the professors who are not specializing
in evolution would be able to refute his
arguments and what I saw roughly at the
time when I was reading this I came
across fantastic debates that you can
find on YouTube between great biologists
do little
and
I forgot the name so but debate was
moderated by Jerry Fowler Reverend Jerry
Powell and it's not easy to debate the
sin and what I think is
uh my daughter by the way will be
passing taking her final on evolutionary
biology I talked to her and from talking
to her I know that evolutionary biology
is taught often as a Dogma sure and I
think this is bad I think it's very good
to give challenging example and
challenge student and Becky so far was
the best challenge for me
okay but the fact that
it's almost Taboo in biology classes I
think it's wrong
and it brings another great right
Joseph Brodsky
and Jose
was sent to a labor camp
in Russia for social parasitism because
his poetry was deemed anti-communist and
explicitly
and I give you citations like script
from his trial
business I don't know Broski but I know
that he writes anti-solving poetry
brosky could you recite a single line
from my points judge nobody will sign
brotsky in my country
so I almost feel that it's like my
daughter was subjected to the same kind
of principle of teaching evolutionary
Bibles no challenges presented as a
Dogma
and I think it's not a good
and what I want to do today I want to
like last told and mention in the very
first talk the standards of proof in
biology is completely different than
standards of proof in us this
and I wanted
people new people in
brave people in computer science Karen
Kansas City and debating evolutionary
Syria I wanted to know that many
biological theories are essentially
logical fallacies based on
poor data
and I will give a few examples in the
last decade I published four papers in
biological journals refuted existing
biological Theory let's go through some
of them and then go to the proof of the
set
City number one the master valuation
proposed by both leading tax return
repeats uh marbles
so you know that over half of our
genomes are repeated DNA there are a
million of copies of value in Elgin
however only very few of them are active
because if many were active active in
the sense they can propagating inside
themselves another place in the gym
because you can imagine that if
thousands of them were active it would
be disaster they would be constantly
bombarded by new insertions of value
very few
and when you look at the data we refuted
this
and this new outlet
and we were very nervous of what Mark
buzzer would say it turned out he said
something even a month so we published
paper in November 2004. in October 2004
marbacher published the paper refusing
his own series so we were a little bit
late but if you didn't you see
example number two
of water regulates protein half one so
yesterday there was a talk about
importance of building uh
uh evaluating uh propensity of different
uh proteins
in the cell it's very important as an
input to
further Evolution analysis but
everything stop at trans
as a result it's already biologically
not very relevant because protein
half-lives vary by five orders of
mortgage
and but before travel is brought in
Half-Life that was a mystery for some
time and Alex awazovsky barely missed
the Nobel Prize
for his pioneering studies on protein
degradation to the point that money
luminaries after 2004 Nobel Prize was
about 20 luminous published the paper in
science arguing that Noble committee
made a mistake by not avoidance Nobel
Prize
of his contribution was connecting enemy
and protein half-life but how many
people in this room know what enemy is
very few okay so I have to explain what
is enemy
so if I ask a question in the class even
in the class of biologists what is the
first letter in all proteins
the most common answer will be mechanian
because start codons code for medallions
this is strong
most proteins don't start from
mechanical because there is extremely
important mechanisms called and terminal
methane cleavage which immediately
constantly cut out
the first metanian if the second time
bacterial to Human
so what it does
so it's essentially
cut methane from if the second
termination is one of the seven specific
evidence it works like a clock it's very
precise
so uh
machovsky and Ralph Bradshaw from UCSF
essentially refused essentially was the
first to try to explain what enemy does
it regulates protein Half-Life because
if they all start from maintenance there
is little variability
in the starting position and in this way
it exposes 8000 minutes as a potential
uh
and this year we refuted this connection
and we showed that and also predicted
completely different mechanism of why it
is happening to what enemy is trying to
achieve and why it is important
and in this case the world ignore was
about to what butchowsky and Bradshaw
will tell because Bradshaw is the same
person here and here was our cause so
essentially quarter essentially later he
refuted his own series
and uh
now uh
so any what is interesting then when you
go to original papers
there are really very
uh
very little support from our From
perspective of computational people and
it will sometimes surprising how
gallable
biologist Community can be by accepting
this argument particularly if they
published in high profile types
anyway let's go further and now my goal
today actually where I will be proving
myself is to disprove one more Theory
and it's called Uh random breakage
Theory and I will be asking the same
questions that Mike asked what is the
difference between men and mice but I
will ask it from completely different
angle so if you ask me Mike was very
particular with the data I'm very naive
if you ask me this is the difference
between human and mouse
take humans you know
all 23 Amazon cut it into 280 pieces
shot drop them on the floor shuffles
them and glue in the New Order
you will get roughly the architecture of
the mileage
okay I will show it on a set of how it
looks like on a single X chromosome
uh X chromosome with special dreams it's
the only chromosome which retains all
its genes from a million Evolution so
genes do not jump from X Amazon to other
chromosome you can think about this as
me dream subject about the culture and
you can think about Mouse and human X
chromosome as pieces consistent of 11
long so-called blocks or Symphony blocks
and if you have red block here and red
block here they roughly consist of the
same gene going in the same order of
course there are some small variation
but this is a big picture of what's
Happening is it clear
now the question is what is the
evolutionist scenario for transforming
one genome into nothing
to answer this question we need to know
what has the typical biological
operations transformation convention
this is well known for example the most
common operation is biology call it
inversion but it's loaded carbon
mathematics that's why we invented 20
years ago we invented term reversal so
we will use the term reversal to
basically take a chunk of the genome
flip it over and of course genome viewed
as not a genome is a permutation of
dreams for us and it's signed
permutation because genes have
directions that's why this is a spinous
11 because depending on the Strand is
looking one on another Direction and
when we flip directions signs of flipped
element change
okay
so
you can think this is
inversion is a dramatic transformation
of the Visa Journal of course most of
them are little
so we can think about them as
evolutionary earthquake happening
because we don't see many human
will be a significant inversion I'm
talking about series and versions
inversions of these spans of millions of
nuclear attacks we see differences
between two humans that amount to there
are many inversions between every two
people in this room but this is small
inversions that come maybe a few hundred
nucleotides maybe a thousands but I'm
talking about dramatic events
do you think this but the spectrum of
ones that occur should be very Broad and
then they're weeded out very quickly the
big ones will read out very quickly by
selection
uh
I that's a deep question there is a long
answer to this question but if I start
answering we won't be able to finish
uh
uh so those are earthquake and then
question arises
if if we compare them to earthquake are
not happening in Moscow but happening in
San Francisco are there any areas in the
genome
where earthquake are happening over and
over again or in other words other
fragile regions in the general where
Evolution can break genome and special
leading to new species
to yeah leading to newspapers the
arrangements are very important
evolutionary because they create
reproductory often create reproductory
per year between different subpopulation
and difference from rotations single
point rotation so this is the question
we're asking
and of course we are interested that
evolutionary scales around of course
rearrangement all the time in cancer and
a different time scale but this is a
rearrangements that lead to death of
individuals so we are not interested in
them they're interested in
rearrangements that retain over the
course of evolution uh presumably
neutral or beneficial
well
and the question is
let's say in this scenario this is
totally arbitrary scenarios today
millions of possible scenarios
let's try to see how it works so we've
done this first reversal there are two
earthquakes happening here and here
right we continue two miles away
tomorrow's great two more slick and
finally rearrangement hotspot there was
a rearrangement happening in this small
regions this regions are very small they
are not shown to scales okay
if I wouldn't show them in scales that
these blocks will be right next to each
other and finally the first uh
rearrangement hotspot and then there the
raster is three golden breaks three okay
but this is arbitrary scenario that has
may have nothing to do with this
Evolution very small so we have no
evidence that's right
chromosomes
uh so far I will I will answer this
question a little bit later so far I'm
wondering talking about bacterial
chromosome my symbolism
in three minutes I will switch to
multiply promise
okay so 40 years ago so someone came up
with this random breakage model the
chromosome evolution is random uh and it
became very prominent and extremely well
cited paper particularly after not doing
Taylor book 30 years ago and not doing
Taylor Made this to ask this question
what happened if we apply any random
reverse to a chromosome consisting of
MGS can be predict how many blocks could
these K genes will be generated
and of course we can right and if we can
predict can be compared prediction with
what we see in real genomes and if the
corresponding distribution match then we
just prove the random breakage mode
right
so that's what they've done
and of course they immediately observe
that if you start cutting a string at
random position the lens of symphony
blocks will follow exponential
distribution and they compared what is
happening what they see in real life in
real life even when the new 30 years ago
they knew so little about comparative
architecture of human and most but still
there was a good feeling 10 years later
there was a fantastic fit and that's why
every biologist thought that's great
another in Taylor an owner a Visionaries
and it became a Dogman in every high
profile papers
in the following year Zub was a
repetition of the statement and indeed
we observed we look at the symphony
blocks and of course they follow the
rabbit breakage Center
so
anyway now let's talk a little bit about
mathematics let's go to prove of the
cell
so what is a reversal given a string
reversal basically does this
and flip it turn it into a different
strength right so I just flipped
identity permutation into a different
permutation is it clear
okay
uh and this reversal introduced two
break points
like irregularities in general string
shouldn't be stand next to a but it
stands next to it there's a result of
this permutation and there are many
different rearrangements scenario for
transforming a given permutation let's
say to Identity this one of them but
this is the fastest one
well definitely not because this is
faster but can we do even faster can we
turn one gentleman to another interest
with Just Three Rivers and we Define
reversal distance as the minimum number
of reversals to transform one side
permutation into another sign
permutation okay
and we'll talk with this reversal
distance problem calculate the reversal
distance and of course you can label uh
the last permutations where you want it
will always label it by identity so it
will be sorted by a reversal problem
calculates the reversal distance between
the atom rotation and the identity
permutation plus one plus two plus
that's our goal and now let's switch
answer your question rearrangement the
tumor in multicameral genome so far we
only talk about single harmless
now uh
this is a bookcase example or probably
the most famous example of realism in
biomedical sense
two chromosome 9.
uh 22
undergoes the following transformation
you can send that chromosome nine break
somewhere chromosome 22 breaks somewhere
and then they glued in the wrong way
okay
is it clear what's happening
there are very important dreams called
BCR and abl that are not supposed to be
together but suddenly they're together
and forming confusion
and this Fusion Gene completely disrupt
regulation
and leads to essentially a landmark of
uh leukemia type special type of
chemicals
so
that's how it's done is it clear what is
done computationally
good and the good news is that this
argument is the most knowledge of this
mechanism resulted in arguably
undoubtedly probably the most successful
anti-cancer drug it's glibic it's a
miracle pill if somebody has CML it's
actually treatable and
and completely based on the knowledge of
of what's happening and that's why there
are so much interest these days in
figuring out water arrangements are
happening in that
okay but now our computational task
becomes much more complex before we talk
about reversal and it still was unclear
how to design efficient algorithm now we
talk about translocation two chromosomes
changing in this way like I show here
and there are also fusions and visions
of chromosomes that you can think about
as kind of degenerative ways to
translate
right
so under all those four operations each
of them biologically very reasonable in
if you open human genetics biomedical
books there will be hundreds of examples
for each of them so under this for
operation I wanted to design an
algorithm that given one multiple
multi will transform it into another
multi-harmison which is a plausible
evolutionary scenario
and now
to the uh
Computer Science History problems of
this type and the first contribution
was actually done by Gates and proper
Dimitri and Gates is exactly the gates
you think about
and Christos probably can tell your
story later how it happened but that was
an excellent paper of course at that
time
it's a complexity status was unknown but
clearly the problem was very hard
uh and late it only became clear is that
it is a pain uh and then we started but
this is sorting by prefix reversals so
it's only when you're allow to make
reversal starting at position one
this is not very biological sorry uh we
are interested in every reversal pause
okay sorting by reversal problems turns
to be pretty pretty hard resulted in a
difficult targeted but thankfully there
is a polynomial algorithm for this it's
just uh rather complex but what was
surprising is that for rearrangements in
multi-rama solid genome there is also a
Syria
that allows us to come up with this
polynomial and fast in practice I'll get
it for sorting by this
razor eclectic sites of operation
and now you're probably waiting for me
to prove this result but I would need
three more hours
and that's why I will do something that
computer scientists always do when they
analyze biological data I will
simplifies the problem
to the point that it becomes relevant
and but in the in my case I do actually
simplify I need to simplify it I mean I
can solve all this problem all the
original results were done in full
generality but since I have very little
time left
I have to be quick and I have to give
you baby version of this set to give you
a better version of the serum I have to
assume that human chromosomes are cyclic
it will adjust a little change to all of
the result after the compute and I will
introduce the notion of two break
distance
okay now how do we represent linear
Amazon I wanted to turn everything into
the language of graph Theory now this is
a genome consistency of two Circle
chromosome let's show this Gene by black
edges black directed edges and let's
show all connections
by Red undirected textures
so this is
how we will represent zero okay
then
what reversal does when reversal
happening it switches this to Flips this
to element how will it affect our
representation well after a we still
have minus B but after minus B we have
to go to minus D so you have to go here
after minus D we have to go to class C
and finally we should change this so
reversal geometrically conveniently look
like this what have we done
I argue that we remove
two edges from our original graph and
added two edges on the same set of four
vertices right so if it doesn't switch
okay so this is reversal we have
intuitive representation for this and
what about fission when we have fission
the essentially change one picture into
this one but it's the same thing we
remove two edges and substitute them by
two other edges it's called to break and
this is an operation I will try I will
be trying to deal with instead of four
different eclectic operations it's also
simplification of biological reality
because in fact I just introduced under
the table some things that doesn't
happen in biology but it's a small thing
not to worry about this
but at least new Stave is still with me
right okay
now how translocation works well this is
translocation on lineage you know you
can circleize them
then you can make a two break on this
genome and then linearize them and you
can see if you go from here here and hit
the same thing so you can model
everything as stupid and that then what
we do we want to compute two break
distances into genome it's minimum
number of to break transforming
convention
now they're very close to that already
so we now go to break one graph
so given to genome
I show here one chromosome but they
might be multi chromosomal of course I
want to find the minimum number of
reversal to transform one into another
now I am surprised that nobody
interrupted me and asked why in the
world you're interested in this minimum
number of reversals uh overall biology
doesn't necessarily follow the welcome
Resort principle I expect this question
I won't give you the answer it doesn't
attack it doesn't affect my results it's
all in the end uh but since I didn't
hear this question I presume I don't
have to
what principle the welcome Resort
principle
okay
or something biology doesn't follow it
either
no but I also doesn't follow by
molecular biologists you don't build
evolutionary tree based on parsimony
principle you use different techniques
to construct real evolutionary tree but
for my arguments
for my argument
it doesn't affect
as you will see but I'm ready as soon as
you ask me a question why I don't look
for the most personal scenario I will
answer this translocation
so I wanted to emulate transfer
translocation on this linear chromosome
the first thing I do and linearize
I Supply
glue
they turn into a circle then I do two
breaks
they transform into
this I'm sorry it's actually this and
then finally I linearize and you can see
I achieved exactly the same result as
shown on the top
is that clear
okay
uh anyway I'm I'm about to prove to
break Syria
so I have to compare p and Q allow me I
mean this is a graphs allow me to
arrange ages of Q that's the way I want
to
and I want to arrange ages of Q exactly
as the ages of Pi ranged
okay and then I will just read Row the
same general key of this new edges let's
say look here after a should go through
C
it is the same genome right
and then I will do this let me
superimpose now p and Q
yeah and this is called the breakpoint
graph
and this is basically the Workhorse of
most evolutionary status
because it contains as a footprint the
history of rearrangements that happen
which is
now what is interesting about this now
comes a little not very intuitive sense
what we will be interested in we will
focus on red and blue edges
and if it will focus on red and blue
edges what they will form we remove
uh black edges
well there is a black matching
and blooming there is a red matching and
blue magic and of course together they
form a collection of non-overlapping
Cycles
the most important thinking evolutionary
in rearrangement studies is this number
the number of Cycles in the breakpoint
graph
okay so if you have uh to Constructor
for multiply chromosomes we simply do
absolutely the same the range edges
exactly like here construct them it's
the same graph superimposed cycle PQ
equals
okay no
this is to check whether you listen to
me
given genome tea
maximizes the cycle number
of course
exactly and it will be the genome that
is exactly
genome itself maximizes the cycle number
because when you superimpose the only
cycles that are left are these three
little Cycles but this is three wheel
breakpoint graph genome reviews itself
and every genome rearrangement when you
move from P to Q you also change the
breakpoint graph all the time so if you
you can think about every evolutionary
scenario as a scenario changing
breakpoint graph we know what was it was
in the beginning and we know what it
will be in the end doesn't matter what
we've done on uh in between right
so
uh
because in the end
the transform genome P into genome Q
so breakpoint graph of p and Q
should the transformance breakpoint
graph of Q and Q
and you just pass the crease when I ask
what will be the number of Cycles in
this graph is genuine with itself it
always looks the same
all right so this series of two break we
know that cycle number all these changes
from what we see in the beginning till
number of genes and this is to break
distance theorem for undergraded class
so every starting point to break changes
P into Q it changes breakpoint graph or
PQ into break one graph of QQ it changes
the cycle or number of PQ into the cycle
number of QQ which we know which means
number of red blue cycle increases in
any transformation by this number number
of blocks minus number of Cycles
and the next question how much each tube
rate can contribute to the circuits
is the answer
what is a two break
we add two edges right and therefore we
can add at most two new Cycles
we also remove two edges which means we
must remove at least one cycle if the
stretches belong to one sunk and
therefore the every two break creates at
most two destroy at least one and
therefore changing the number of Cycles
is always less or equal than one
You just prove is here a two break
increase the number of cycle by at most
one it's already existed two break
increasing number of cycle by one I
don't show it but it's very simple just
homework and home exercise and we know
that every certain Bible to break must
increase number of Cycles by this
and therefore his result to break
distance between genome ski and Q is
this
okay
great
okay now the proof of the
on this result in full generality
for real like if you don't circleize
chromosome you do not allow financing it
will take roughly 40 pages but I save
you from this torture so we can go first
anyway
after we prove the same we actually
compute the two break distance between
human
rights and discrew them
period iCal security
but Chris we haven't come here to
biological theorems this is just a
computer computers
mathematical theorem they are coming to
biological theorem now
okay so we now can compute the
breakpoint the two break distance
between human and mouse very simple just
construct breakpoint graph compute
number of cycle and I want you to
remember
the distance between them is 245. and
now you should really ask questions why
cables the most parsimonious Evolution
doesn't necessarily follow because the
only argument I will use in my
biological argument is the lower bound
and lower bound of course is also
non-trainable right so if it is more
it's even better for me
okay
better for what follows you will see
so but you have to remember the number
245.
and of course there are numerous to 45
step scenario I have no clue which of
them is correct and the true scenario
may have more than two
and now really the proof of biological
Theory
other fragile regions in the human
genome
yes
how would we do this here's an argument
uh
is a random breakage model is correct
then and rearrangement apply to Circle
you'll produce approximately two M
blocks
there is a chance that uh two endpoints
of radiation will fall to the same point
of roughly to the same point but think
about the human genome it's huge the
chances are small if you talk about
reality so far
statistics but I leave it aside so you
are saying that the length of the
segments was the wrong parameter to to
our lives not yet not yet no no it will
it will play role it nothing was wrong
yet in not doing Taylor argument but
I'll come later to uh so since there are
we know that there are 280 human Mouse
sent any blocks how we computed the
separate story we only count large
blocks of which are medium nucleotides
uh long uh since there are 280 human
model Symphony block there must have
been approximately 280 over 2
142 breaks between human and mouse
genome right
my next question
however remember the two breaks area
implies that there were at least 245 and
my next question is 245 is approximately
equal to one
now this is a loaded question you need
some statistics
to demonstrate let's say P value of this
but p-value of this will be so
ridiculous that I won't even tell about
this this is just cannot happen it's
really huge huge difference
cannot happen by chance
and therefore
since 245 is much larger than 140 we
arrived at the contradiction implying
that one of our assumptions is wrong
with each one
General sizes option there was no genome
size assumption the only assumption we
made is the random breakage share Eaves
the random breakage model is correct but
it's only a substance
right yeah in some you can interpret so
we just disproved the random breakage
model
it has to be done with this quotient but
uh let's assume that they paid attention
to statistical issues
and now I really ran out of time should
I continue to finish
okay
now and now I want to talk about
computational tests
versus
biological model maybe I was just
unlucky every biological
study
I was interested in turn out to be wrong
everybody also can see little biological
Theory I was looking at turn out to be
wrong I'm not sending you my name
and uh
it's let's just think what happened
let's say with this random breakage
model how did how did it happen that it
becomes a dominance here
or why have biologists Embrace a random
breakage model it's psychological
sociological question it was a clearly
logical fallacy
random breakage model is not the only
model that complies with the exponential
distribution test I will explain you in
a second that my new model that I will
have to write in a moment complex
equally well with this exponential
everything was right about exponential
distribution but since there are many
things that explain one biological
reality
so Darwin used is one excellent
explanation of biological reality but
has anybody proven that it's the only
one
other maybe other explanation that
explain ever since the Darwinism
explained and doesn't a little bit more
excluding intelligent design
so that's that's an example and
why Wars are being reputed it doesn't
complain obvious certain biological data
and certain algorithmic analysis doesn't
imply with absurd Waypoint reuse test so
we need to change the model but how
and I show you a vote from my
perspective is the reasonable way to fix
the model and still explain biology they
cannot Escape explanation of x minus or
distribution
so current explanation is genome is a
mosaic of fragile regions that take very
little portion of the genome in solid
region that practically cannot be broken
there is not nothing surprising consists
if you you don't want to break ribosomal
joints in half right so definitely is
the average of the genome but what this
model shows is there are huge regions of
the genome that are protected against
fragility huge
and uh
uh okay so why it explains it and this
model explains everything
that's a random broadcast display but
explains more because you only should
assume that fragile region are
distributed randomly in the genome
to arrive to the same exponential
distribution of the symphony blocks
sizes right
and that's why
they come came up with fragile breakage
model so genome model is genome is a
mosaic of
fragile and solid region solid regions
are extremely rarely broken as a result
very small region of the genome is
available for rearrangements uh and is
now is it does it sound reasonable is it
correct
of course it is wrong
of course we are just constantly
approximating the reality so let me show
you what is what is actually uh wrong
with this model so if you compare zeroth
and human
also also pretty much uh deviations of
course
and you're coming right to it's exactly
the right question to ask so uh so it
was of course certain after we
introduced this fragile there was
certain resistance but the number of
papers now supporting this is
overwhelming so I don't think today
people are actually doubt that there are
fragile regions in but there are many
questions and answers that remain
unanswered it's non-constructive proof
right that I get I don't know where's
the federal regional side uh and another
question we should be critical so
biologists were very gullible by
accepting logical fallacy
but just by selling you the cells is
just the results that I just presented
I'm selling you in nasological fallacy
right and I haven't proven that there
are other models that maybe even better
explain what's going on so what is the
size model
we need to look at data and that's why I
think a very important thing in addition
to what last said in the beginning in
addition to generation of people coming
to biologists with different standards
of rigor there are also it's amazing
time because there are amazing amount of
new data currently
right and wearing these two streams I
think is very valuable and we need to
look when we first distribute the random
breakage model we only have this and
this animal it was actually done in the
framework of mouse Consortium
and but now we have minions and when we
have many we can design one more
uh test called multiply break point
reuse tells that I don't have time to
cover and
if you apply this test
to real data you will see the fragile
breakage model largely correct but needs
to be modified here's the modification
yes recent study so what this recent
study revealed is that in every genome
the refrigerant regions but they're not
constant
they die
and they may appear in the general
and predictive power to explain data is
exactly the same in this Theory as
another theory but it explains more and
complies more with this data
and what comes here next so this is a
turnover fragile flight modification on
fragile photo is it correct of course we
don't know because who knows how many uh
more precisely can be but there are very
intriguing questions that this
biological kind of Siri open up
or water whereas the fragile regions
located there is of course a lot of
studies now going this and what causes
structurally why all of a sudden chilled
chunks of the genome there are about
thousands of explanations for this in
many many papers uh proposed but I think
this study opens kind of favors with one
particular explanation and
this particular explanation relates to
another process resolution of burst and
death of repeats that also subject to
person deaths I don't have time to go
into this so do I have three minutes to
finish
okay
so uh
no does this does this model only look
back or does it have any predictive
power right can we if we learn about how
this fragile region are constructed can
we say something about what will happen
with this Cinema in the future can we
make let's say an experiment assumes
that we don't know anything about human
move 16 million years back to the common
ancestor of macaque and human
and based only on this data and
evolution of macaque
make inferences but what will happen in
here because human in the next 16
billion years
okay it turned out that if there is
turnover that transaction regions in
human are probably calculated to these
fragile regions here and then they can
make predictions about what actually are
most likely next breaks in the human
genome and not surprisingly if we want
to learn what are the fragile regions in
human the best they seem to do is to
sequence 200 different species of monkey
next and carefully look because
they're the most closest that's why
turnover in them is roughly at the same
places where they're inhuman and look at
where they were broken in recent 15 20
30 million years of evolution and we
verify this prediction by making this
kind of sort argument to this model
anyway
it's all exciting but I don't have time
so uh this was a joint work with Max
Alexander
thank you
so I have some questions so it's it's I
could not understand why it is
um hard to really validate the the
assumptions on the breakage with all the
data that we have today and techniques
for ancestral reconstruction of genomes
still you cannot really see if your
algorithm and prediction it's not
prediction if you're auditing they have
very few genomes that have reason 20
million years
from Human sickness they have very few
such animals so fun and everything that
goes beyond this let's say moms of
course we can find Regions that are in
mouse or set between Mouse and reds that
are broken but since there is a turnover
of this region since they move all the
time and now there is a mechanism why
they move then predictions on distant
species don't tell us what's happening
now with this EQ so fast don't tell us
where the regions are currently located
in Hume
I mean reconstruction not prediction but
to the past to to Really to to Really
measure your your whether your
parsimonials or whether you are going to
it's not predictions
of Destruction
more validation with respect to to all
the data the richness or are you talking
about reconstruction of ancestral
genomes oh this is a very active area uh
data counselor work actively in this
area and I think this algorithm will be
broken this area we have two algorithms
on one web server for this and I think
this algorithm worked quite well like if
you look from the common sense
perspective most likely they reconstruct
really well ancient organization of
ancestors so you could so so when this
was asked about the giraffe you could
see if you you you could see if you
really reconstruct well the the size of
the or not the size the history of the
there is no doubt as soon as we have
hundreds mammalian genome sequence we
will have very accurate information
about genomic architecture of ancestor
so we know we will know what happens
with water arrange what happened on the
past when giraffes stop growing could
snack
kind of related animals that David
Hauser showed that this is a very
accurate prediction
uh
there is there is that Houser algorithm
there are two of our organizers there
house algorithm and they all roughly
produce the same for example
when these genomes came out that you
tend to get the break points at
duplicated genes
where you obviously have the biology for
recombinations that seeing generally
uh
I do not know I do not know
you know I guess a lot of these events
should be meiotic and they wouldn't
necessarily be fragile sites in germ
cells and in fact there are meiotic hot
spots the better way to model see this
right from Molly
Syria's work so this this doesn't
doesn't provide any insight into biology
of what's happening it's more like
mechanics of what's happening with
exception of it provides inside what
triggers this reading
and I can tell you that they are
triggered by
tandem segmental duplications two
segmental duplication Longs flanking
Theory
what's the mechanism for the
defining a fragile what defines the
pressure uh
great question uh so Zara as I said
maybe 10 different hypothesis of reward
from triggers fragility and I favor one
of them recent one
and this is fragilities
triggered by a couple of very long
semantle duplications that say sound
maybe ten thousand long that have
ability to in 3D somehow to promote this
to triggers this effect
but there are 10 answers there will be
10 hours at least
yeah
James jump in and out of the X
chromosome that's a good question so uh
there is this Effect called X chromosome
in activation because you don't want to
have like you don't want human and man
to be too different and there are many
genes that have nothing to do with this
sex on X chromosome so if there was no
exam
X chromosome what is the right name
deactivate deactivation right Zen some
of us would have twice large expression
than us
two two things one is a very
straightforward question
um could you elaborate just a little bit
what what defines the pressure range
what kind of repeats what is duplicated
and what What is the characteristic size
of that definition okay so that's by the
way subject of active studies right now
but in the published papers
so the hypothesis says if zura tu
segmental duplications
they're not tandem I'm sorry matching
symbol duplication one is like this and
another is wash my hands like this then
it promotes ability a better ability to
make a
rearrangements whose end points are
located in these regions
for reasonable it's a really very good
mechanistic explanation that I sent many
biologists would accept but until
recently until 2009 paper on this in
genome research there was no evidence
for this
foreign
with multiplied by that yes so it was
completely natural to accept that you
know their hypothesis what was what was
wrong there is
the Ridiculousness of accepting that
hypothesis is some sort of final truth
but that's not a logical house there was
no log no violation of logic so the
typical epistemological velocity right
but that's that's that's actually
substitutes the difference in
uh standards of logical arguments
between two communities Computer
Sciences would never be able to publish
a paper where computer science would
present a hypothesis and not even make a
footnote that is probably one of 100
different explanations
as a result the paper is published in
high profile journals 10 years later
saying that it's a dog ten days later
most of the community think it's a Dogma
and that's what's happening yes
explanations
but they are not all equals another
and I do argue that there are real model
is more equal because it's the simplest
does not have to be the truth once you
come up with that or with another cast
eat nicely can use it then you replace
it in another house
so yeah you agree yeah